당연하게도, 컴퓨터는
소인수를 반복적으로 검색하는 것만으로 눈 깜짝할 사이에 알려줄 수 있어요.
또 다른 예시가 있어요. 이 숫자를 읽어보진 않을게요.
약 3.4 콰투오르데실리온인데, 이런 이름이 있다는 것 자체가 좀 이상하다고 인정할 수밖에 없어요.
어쨌든, 46개의 십진 자릿수를 가지고 있고 여기서
소인수분해를 볼 수 있어요.
컴퓨터도 이걸 알려줄 수 있어요. 저는 Python용 기호 수학 라이브러리에 포함된
인수분해 방법을 사용해서 이 숫자를 인수분해했어요.
몇 초 걸렸는데, 특별히 긴 시간은 아니지만 눈에 띄는 지연이 있었어요.
물론 factor N 방법은 소인수를 단순하게 검색해서 이 소인수분해를 찾지는 않아요.
실제로는 여러 알고리즘의 하이브리드를 사용하는데,
그중 하나가 colored row 알고리즘이에요. 이건 소인수를
단순하게 반복 검색하는 것보다
더 정교한 인수분해 알고리즘이에요.
꽤 큰 숫자처럼 보일 수 있지만,
계산 문제의 입력으로서는 사실 그렇게 크지 않아요.
겨우 46글자에 불과해요.
하나 더 예시가 있어요. 309개의 십진 자릿수를 가진 숫자예요.
이진 표기법으로 쓰면 1,024비트를 가지고 있고 그래서
RSA1024라고 불려요.
이 숫자의 소인수분해는 현재 알려져 있지 않아요.
이 숫자는 RSA Laboratories가
1991년부터 2007년까지 운영한 RSA 인수분해 챌린지에서 나온 거예요.
이 숫자를 포함해서 점점 커지는
다양한 숫자들의 소인수분해에 상금을 걸었는데,
이건 10만 달러짜리였어요.
하지만 그 상금은 수여된 적이 없어요.
RSA 공개키 암호 시스템의 보안은
정수 인수분해의 어려움에 기반하고 있어요.
인수분해를 할 수 있으면
시스템을 깨뜨릴 수 있어요. 그래서 챌린지의 목적은 기본적으로
인수분해의 최신 기술 수준을 추적하는 거였어요.
결론은 이 숫자를
인수분해하는 것은 현재 우리 능력 밖이라는 거예요.
우리가 아는 한, 이 문제 자체가
고전 컴퓨터로 실제로 풀기엔 너무 복잡해요.
참고로, 지금까지 인수분해된 가장 큰 RSA 챌린지 숫자는 250개의 십진 자릿수를 가지고 있어요.
화면에서 읽기 좀 어려울 수 있는데,
RSA250의 소인수분해가 여기 있어요.
이건 2020년에 수체 체(number field sieve)라는 알고리즘을 사용해서 이뤄졌고, 전 세계 수만 대의
컴퓨터가 참여한 집단적 노력이었어요.
자, 이제 다른 계산 문제를
생각해 볼게요. 두 비음수 정수의 최대공약수,
줄여서 GCD를 계산하는 문제예요.
두 비음수 정수의요.
문제의 설명은 이래요. 입력은 이번에는
두 개의 숫자, N과 M으로 구성돼요.
둘 다 0인 경우는
아니라고 가정할 거예요.
목표는 이 두 숫자의
GCD를 계산하는 거예요. N과 M을 모두 나누어 떨어지게 하는 가장 큰 정수 D예요.
N과 M의 소인수분해를
생각해 보면, GCD는 N과 M 모두를 나누는 모든 소수의 곱이에요.
두 소인수분해에 나타나는 거듭제곱의 최솟값으로
올린 거예요.
그래서 정수 인수분해 문제와
관련이 있지만, 컴퓨터로 풀기에는 훨씬, 훨씬 더 쉬워요.
수천 자릿수의 숫자에 대해서도
눈 깜짝할 사이에 GCD를 계산할 수 있어요.
화면에 예시를 보여드리는 건 좀 무의미해요. 화면 전체를 숫자로 채워도
여전히 이 문제의
쉽게 풀 수 있는 인스턴스를 설명하는 거일 테니까요.
하지만 관심이 있으시면, 동영상 설명의 링크를 따라가서 이 강의의 교재 페이지를 보시면 코드 셀을 찾을 수 있어요.
제가 말하는 종류의 계산들인데,
큰 숫자의 GCD를 계산하는 것도 포함돼 있고,
직접 시도해 볼 수 있어요.
질문은 왜 GCD를 이렇게 쉽게 계산할 수 있느냐는 거예요.
그 질문에 대한 답은 GCD를 계산하는
효율적인 알고리즘이 있다는 거예요.
그중에는 2,000년 이상 전에 발견된 유클리드 알고리즘이 있지만, 다른 효율적인
GCD 알고리즘들도 있어요.
물론 여기서 고전 알고리즘에 대해 이야기하고 있는 거니까, 또 다른 질문이 나와요.
RSA1024 같은 숫자를
눈 깜짝할 사이에 인수분해할 수 있게 해주는
효율적인 고전 알고리즘이 있을 수 있을까요?
답은 네, 있을 수 있어요. 인수분해를 위한 효율적인 고전
알고리즘이 절대적으로 있을 수 있고, 현재로서는 그 가능성을
배제할 방법을 모르겠어요. 우리가 말할 수 있는 건
아직 하나를 찾지 못했다는 것뿐이에요.
우리가 아는 모든 고전
인수분해 알고리즘에서 우리는 본질적으로 여전히
인수를 검색하고 있고
그래서 RSA1024 같은 숫자는
우리의 능력 밖이에요.
반면에 효율적인 GCD 알고리즘은
그런 방식으로 작동하지 않아요.
최대공약수를 검색하지 않아요.
같은 두 숫자를 곱하는 것과 비슷한 비용의
기계적 절차로 효과적으로 만들어내요.
이에 대해서는 강의
후반부에서 좀 더 이야기할게요.